liebe mitbürgerinnen und liebe mitbürger
spätestens seit dieser woche wissen wir
wir sind jetzt in einer sehr ernsten
phase der korona pandemie tag für tag
steigt die zahl der neuinfektionen
sprunghaft die pandemie breitet sich
wieder rapide aus schneller noch als zu
beginn vor mehr als einem halben jahr
der vergleichsweise entspannte sommer
ist vorbei jetzt stehen uns schwierige
monate bevor wie der winter wird wie
unser weihnachten wird das entscheidet
sich in diesen kommenden tagen und
wochen das entscheiden wir alle durch
unser handeln
ich möchte ihnen sagen was das nach
meiner überzeugung bedeutet wir müssen
jetzt alles tun damit das virus sich
nicht unkontrolliert ausbreitet dabei
zählt jetzt jeder tag dafür müssen die
kontaktpersonen jedes infizierten
menschen benachrichtigt werden um die
ansteckungskette zu unterbrechen
die gesundheitsämter leisten dabei
großartiges aber wo die zahl der
infizierten zu hoch wird da kommen sie
nicht mehr hinterher
was kann jede und jeder von uns also
dazu beitragen dass die zahlen wieder
herunter gehen sehr viel
das allermeiste schon einfach dadurch
dass jede und jeder einzelne konsequent
den mindestabstand war dem mund nasen
schutz trägt die hygiene regeln einhält
aber wir müssen jetzt noch weiter gehen
die wissenschaft sagt uns klar die
ausbreitung des virus hängt direkt an
der zahl der kontakte der begegnungen
die jeder von uns hat wenn jeder von uns
seine begegnungen außerhalb der eigenen
familie jetzt eine zeit lang deutlich
verringert dann kann es gelingen den
trend zu immer mehr infektionen zu
stoppen und umzukehren
genau das ist heute mein appell an sie
treffen sie sich mit deutlich weniger
menschen ob außerhalb oder zu hause
ich bitte sie verzichten sie auf jede
reise die nicht wirklich zwingend
notwendig ist
auf jede feier die nicht wirklich
zwingend notwendig ist
bitte bleiben sie wenn immer möglich
zu hause an ihrem wohnort ich weiß das
klingt nicht nur hart das ist im
einzelfall auch ein schwerer verzicht
aber wir müssen ihnen nur zeitweilig
leisten und wir leisten ihnen letztlich
für uns selbst für die eigene gesundheit
und die all derer denen wir eine
erkrankung ersparen können dafür dass
unser gesundheitswesen nicht überfordert
wird dass die schulen und kitas unserer
kinder geöffnet bleiben für unsere
wirtschaft und unsere arbeitsplätze
was hat uns denn so vergleichsweise gut
durch das erste halbe jahr der pandemie
gebracht dass wir zusammen gestanden und
die regeln eingehalten haben aus
rücksicht und vernunft
das ist das wirksamste mittel das wir
zurzeit gegen die pandemie haben jetzt
ist es nötiger denn je
ich danke ihnen